- Also hard to deal with for you
when you were out there
was mice.
You don't like them, do you?
No, I do not like mice.
- I mean, not at all.
- No.
Why don't we take a look
at the mice in Larry's house?
They were getting really bold.
They were like, crawling
right out of my shelter,
and just basically
flipping me the paw.
And I'm like, you know what?
I'm gonna get you.
[bleep] mouse.
If you stick around, I
will stab you in the throat
with my knife, and eat you.
That [inaudible] definitely
given me a few calories.
It's been fun making,
been fun improving upon.
Boo-yah!
Lighter than a pancake, baby.
[shouting] Mice are all gone.
Yeah!
All right, you gotta tell
me-- what did they taste like?
Just-- like victory.
[laughter]
Like victory?
Over, and over, and over again.
All right, so take me--
the breaking point how to be the
bear spray in the house, right?
I mean, that's a-- that's
a pretty drastic measure,
I would think.
How did you get there?
These mice keep crawling into
my grass bed, which was fine
if they were down by my feet.
But they were right
under my head.
And I actually thought--
I mean, there was a couple
of times I thought they were
crawling up, like,
going to get in my head,
or gnaw on my ear, or something.
And it was-- it was stressful.
I didn't-- I didn't want that.